people have so much entitlement in  today's day and age they really do like  oh I got invited on fresh and fist  podcast oh cool I'm gonna rock up late  drink all their alcohol be have my  social medias blown up by their a  million subscriber audience have all my  only fans account blown up by their  million subscriber audience which does  happen we know it happens right and  there's still  gonna talk speak out of line be  disrespectful to Myron because he said  something they don't agree with they're  gonna be really rude to him and try to  talk over the top of him right not obey  the house rules like our producer here  kind of laid down before it's a more  thing right  it comes from this place of entitlement  it's a real lack of respect